despite my proclivity to feel guilt
which is quite substantive and despite
my temperamental unwillingness to engage
in Conflict not only do I not see what I
did wrong I think what I've done on the
Public Communication front is my
responsibility as a
clinician to tell the truth about what I
see so we'll make it
[Music]
public
dad nice to see you hey mick how you
doing I'm not doing too bad how are
you good actually all things considered
I'm in Milwaukee looking forward to the
presidential debate tonight that's fun
um you know I'm perplexed I would say
about the situation in Canada I've been
thinking about it this morning as you
know the the the court that we appealed
the College of psychologists decision to
decided that the college
has it's within the college's purview to
stop me from having any political
opinions as far as I can tell the the um
the decision which I posted on Twitter
and will post in the description of this
video starts out by making a case for
the fundamental reality of freedom of
speech for Canadians in Canada and then
says but and that's always a bad start
when you're talking about freedom of
speech but apparently the college has
the right to decide that I can be
re-educated
forcibly with the risk of my license
essentially because I made political
statements that the members of the
college don't agree with and those ex
those those um opinions involve two
criticisms of Justin Trudeau one
criticism of his chief of staff one
criticism of an Ottawa city counselor
and then my objection on Joe Ro Rogan to
The Climate apocalyptic fear-mongering
that idiot tyrants are foisting on the
general population now apparently that
makes makes me unprofessional and a
disgrace to the profession such that I
am now going to be required the college
can go ahead with this to put me into a
re-education program with their
so-called social media experts and
that's also by the way a profession that
does not exist until I learn my lesson
whatever that is regardless of how much
time that takes by their judgment or
they can take my license away and so the
the court says well of course you have
freedom of speech Dr Peterson but
because you're a professional you're
bound by your Professional Organization
and apparently they're not bound even
though they're a government organization
fundamentally apparently they're not
bound by that fundamental constitutional
axom and so that shows you all you
Canadians who are listening and everyone
outside of the country who might be the
least bit interested in Canada that
shows you exactly what our bloody
Constitution is worth and if adans are
so daff that they don't think that
that's a problem well they're going to
figure it out over the next 15 years
because there's
absolutely no excuse for this so that's
what I'm thinking now there's part of me
that's
thinking well look
Peterson the College of psychologists is
after you you've taken it to court now
the judges have decide that you're wrong
maybe you're wrong and I think well I
expressed political sentiment and I'm
actually informed and so for the life of
me I can't see how I'm wrong I think I
have a responsibility to say what I
think and I think many people agree with
that and I think the fundamental
consequence of that around the world has
been massively beneficial to people so I
think I think number one what the hell
and number two bring it on and see what
happens because I will make absolutely
every bit of
public in a way that the college and the
courts can hardly even
imagine so away we go so that's how I'm
doing that's how you're doing okay but
good yeah but good you know I mean I
didn't look the court decision was worse
than I thought it would be I was already
pessimistic I figured the court
would take the coward's way out and
basically upgrade the college for
procedural inadequacy because one of the
things the college did which is just
beyond comprehension as far as I'm
concerned is pursue these complaints
that were uh put forward by people
distributed all over the
world who then claimed in writing
falsely to be my clients when in fact
they were never my clients and not only
were they not my clients they had
nothing to do with anyone who was ever a
client of mine and so I figured at least
the Court would say well you know of
course you have the right to police
professionals because you're a
professional governing body but they
didn't even do that they just basically
said well of course you have the right
to freedom of speech except when it
comes to let's say political opinions so
you know then what right do you have at
all and you know it's terrible Michaela
because I know perfectly well from
talking to many Physicians physicians in
particular but also lawyers and
psychologists that no one in Canada
arguably and this is also extremely
strange it's surreal there's no one in
Canada except me that's actually in a
position to fight this because it's
hyper expensive and I don't know if my
insurance will cover it it's hyper
expensive
it's stressful it's complex it's timec
consuming it could involve the uh
suspension of my license
um and there's not really anything that
that can be done to me that's a threat
I'm not serving as a clinician I don't
have a practice anymore because that
became impossible even though I love
doing it and I'm also not very happy
about that so I'm like the person who
can do this and Canadians have no idea
to what degree Professionals in Canada
are now
required not to say what they think or
to lie outright so for example
therapists are required by law to lie
about let's say the gender identity of
minors and so for me especially on the
therapy side if if you're required by
law and by your Professional
Organization to lie cowardly you're done
as a therapist because the only thing
you've got as a therapist is honesty
that's it honesty is what's Curative
so
you know it's just part of how surreal
the world is and and particularly how
surreal Canada is it's uh it's hard to
Fathom it is hard to Fathom can I read
just a couple of sentences from the
decision so people have an idea of
what's in here it's linked below people
can read the entire thing but there's
Parts like this is how it begins when
individuals join a regulated profession
they do not lose their Charter right to
freedom of expression at the same time
however they take on obligations and
must abide by the rules of their
regulatory body that may limit their
freedom of expression that's just one
sentence after another that's how it
starts yeah yeah perfect that it's a
great thing to highlight you know it's
it's like well you have this fundamental
right but well but what what rules
there's what there's a rule a there's a
rule is that right that the College of
psychologists has that I can't criticize
Justin Trudeau on Twitter that's a rule
is it and if someone anywhere in the
world complains about the fact that I've
criticized Justin Trudeau let's say that
all of a sudden that's a rule even
though it wasn't a rule and of course I
get to criticize Justin trudo not only
because he richly deserves it in every
way you can possibly imagine but because
that's actually what freedom of speech
means so I have no idea what the court
means by you know abiding by the rules
so the rules are whatever the bloody
College of psychologists determines
constitutes a
rule after the
fact given their complete freedom
to make manifest any rules they want
yeah it's it's beyond comprehension and
yeah but but I have freedom of speech
it's like do I now what do I get to talk
about apparently I can't even talk about
the weather you know here's here's
another fact this is literally the
truth people can submit complaint to the
College of psychologists from anywhere
in the world and so someone in the stat
submitted a complaint about the conver
the last conversation I had with Joe
Rogan where I yeah expressed my doubts
about the validity of economic pre
predictions based on climate
science they the complainant submitted
the entire transcript right a three-hour
conversation as evidence of my
unprofessional behavior and the college
which did not have to pursue that
complaint went forward with
it so like okay I talked to Joe for
three hours apparently everything I said
in that three hours was unprofessional
and a disgrace to the to the
profession so
like well what am I supposed to do about
that the answer is well we're going to
appeal the decision I will take this to
the Supreme Court I don't think that any
judges will have either the wisdom or
the courage to rule about this properly
except at the Supreme Court level and
I'm not particularly optimistic about
that
either I'm not optimistic about that
either I don't see how you can win this
without overturning colleges in
general and I don't like that's not a
good look for the colleges to lose this
so won't the Supreme Court I know
they're not supposed to to be pressured
but won't they what's the benefit for
them for ruling in your favor other
than they support well they would
support the most
fundamental principle of a free Society
right it's like why do you have the
right to freedom of speech well the
answer is is because there's no
difference between free speech and
thinking no difference between free
speech and dialogue and no difference
between free speech and problem Sol a
negotiation and so and therefore peace
If you eliminate that people can no
longer think they can no longer adapt
they can no longer negotiate they no
longer even
know how to orient themselves in the
world and so in principle the advantage
uh for the Supreme Court is that they
rule in favor of the most fundamental
principle upon which civil democracy
itself is predicated now I don't think
we have the right to free speech in
Canada I think this this uh this
decision today demonstrates that
obviously I saw the same thing with the
Law Society in Canada partly was why I'm
not surprised at this ruling I've been
through this before and I see that
Canada's walked down that idiot path for
at least 30 years so our country is in
well this is where I start to get
doubtful it's like either I'm wrong or
the country is in trouble now to tell
you the truth
I would rather be wrong but I've thought
it through it's like okay what did I do
exactly none of my clients complained
that it has nothing to do with
this and I express my political opinions
which I have a right to do which I
believe were
correct I think that and Canadians agree
with this now the last poll indicated
that Canadians believe that Justin
Trudeau is the worst prime minister
we've ever had well that was sort of my
point a year ago you know and so if I
can't say that and yet a majority of
Canadians believe it to be true and
believe me a lot more of them are going
to believe
that a lot more are going to believe
that in the relatively near future in
what sense do I have anything even
approximating freedom of speech and if
yeah I can't have that opinion and
therefore in principle no one can then
what do we do when we're stuck with a
prime minister let's say who everyone
has decided is the worst prime minister
the country's ever had well move run if
you can well this is another reason you
know why I'm in a position that I can
fight this because the worst thing that
could happen is the college can take
away my license now I already know that
if my license gets taken away there are
other
jurisdictions that will grant me a
license the next
day and you know there's a real ComEd
there's a real ComEd element to that
because I could lose my license in
Ontario and instantly be licensed in at
least three other
jurisdictions and so that's not going to
look very
good with regard to the Ontario College
of psychologists well they got rid of
you well and fair enough and if that's
what they want I mean the other problem
that the college is going to face is
that and I don't know exactly what
they're going to make of this
but all the people who are involved in
this prosecution are going to find very
soon that this will eat their
life so you know from a media
perspective I've offered yeah well I've
offered to the college to negotiate I
actually have a solution in mind and
I've heard the
odd comment indicating that maybe that's
a possibility I reached out a month ago
with an idea they haven't got back to me
I think they were waiting for this
decision to tell you the truth and of
course they're going to be entirely
emboldened by this I know the solution
which I'm I'm not going to discuss in
this podcast you know I have to talk to
them first I have a reasonable
solution but um and I also know or think
I know you know you might ask well why
is the college doing this and my
suspicions are because I've this is
we've been through this before you know
when Cambridge University cancelled my
the seminar I was going to conduct there
on Exodus I found out eventually that it
was basically one person who was behind
all of that there were two more that
were associated with that person who are
pushing the college to go after me for
whatever the hell their reasons are you
know maybe they disagree with my
political opinions particularly on the
transf front and that was the that was
the tweet I think that really probably
initiated all this right I tweeted
about Elliot
page and so I'm perfectly happy that I
tweeted that particular tweet and I also
think in five years nobody will admit
that they were ever in favor of any of
this right this is far worse than the
lobotomies of the 1930s this is
inexcusable you know I I read one poor
kid today on Twitter D transitioner was
decrying his castration fancy that and
pointing out for example that you know
he's a young guy he has no sexual drive
whatsoever and he said well you know
what what am I going to do what have I
lost I can't believe I was so stupid as
to have gone through with this it's like
you know fair enough kid you probably
should have woken up but the people who
facilitated that transformation your
therapists and your surgeons what Happ
Do no harm yeah right I should also
point out just so just so everyone is
aware of
this surgeons are much more likely to be
Psychopathic than people in the typical
profession that's a well documented
phenomenon in the psychological
literature now it's not only surgeons
obviously you see it that in other
professions as well but if you happen to
be s istic and
Psychopathic a profession that allows
you to cut people up that's that that uh
and you think well there no people like
that it's like well I think they just
arrested some nurse in the UK for
killing a bunch of babies in her
Psychopathic and sadistic Manner and so
if you don't think there are people like
that you're naive beyond belief and you
better bloody well pray that you never
meet anyone like that because they're
looking for someone just as naive as you
to have their way with there are
countries now that have outlawed
surgery for minors transgender surgeries
for miners like I believe Sweden has
they didn't exactly out Outlaw it they
um I got corrected on that claim by
Community notes on Twitter well what
happened was they they've
restricted surgery to minors to clinical
trials which is you know it's a detail
they they' backtracked there's no doubt
Denmark France Sweden the
UK Holland the Netherlands which is
particularly relevant because that's
where this gender affirming surgical
idiocy first made itself manifest the
Europeans have woken up to the fact that
well you know what turns out that
there's no evidence that sterilizing
young people and cutting off their
breasts makes them happier isn't that a
shock
yep I think this is going to BL this is
an argument that has to be had right now
and it's going to there's going to be
such push back from people who have gone
through these surgeries starting now
it's already happening yeah yeah yeah
you had some more things to read from
the decision well there there are a
couple of other I don't know if they're
funny but there are a couple of other
parts just to clarify what's going on it
say this decision that they've come to
ordered Dr Peterson as a registered
member of the college to complete a
specified continuing education or
remedial program a scirp regarding
professionalism in public
statements uh the order is not
disciplinary clarifies that here and
does not prevent that was that's good
right it's not a punishment you just
have to pay for things you don't want to
do yeah right I have to pay for things I
don't want to do it's also not specified
so that what's specified is that I have
to be retrained what's specified in this
specification is that I have to be
retrained
regardless of how long that takes until
the people who are responsible for the
retraining have decided that I've
learned my lesson right so don't tell me
that's specified and don't bloody well
lie you pikers and tell me that that's
not disciplinary how pathetic can you
get it's like if you're going to come
after me why don't you bloody well admit
that you're disciplining me which is
absolutely 100% obvious especially
because you're also claiming that I
deserve to be disciplined you know it's
like claiming you're in charge in favor
of freedom of speech and then telling me
that well except that you know you're a
professional and of course we wouldn't
want professionals to be able to you
know tell the truth or say what they
think because everyone wants their
professionals to lie to them because
that's how you get the best advice and
guidance
obviously yeah I I think what what
shocks me about this is you are
basically being brought to task Over The
Joe Rogan podcast one The Joe Rogan
podcast which is insane um and over
political tweets like it says right here
a tweet on February 19th in which Dr
Peterson commented that an Ottawa city
councelor was an appalling
self-righteous moralizing thing an
appalling self-righteous moralizing
thing yeah well I used thing because I
didn't want to get in trouble on the
pronoun front oh well I don't think that
panned out well well we'll see and so
far it's called cused a certain amount
of trouble okay so there was the OT city
of counselor yeah what other what other
so uh tweet on January 2nd in which Dr
Peterson responded to an individual who
expressed concern over
overpopulation that's how it's
worded uh and your response was you're
free to leave at any point the person
actually said just so we get this right
that there were two many people on the
planet now I'm not very happy with that
statement at all cuz I listen to people
I listen to what people say and when
people say well there should only be 500
million people on the planet because
that's what the planet can sustain I
think what do you plan to do with the
other 7 billion 500 million they're
inconvenient are they and you what do
you think they should be dispensed with
just exactly what the hell are you
saying and if you think that there are
too many people well what makes you so
sure that you're not one of them
especially if you're the one that's
concerned about it you know if the
Lifeboat is too crowded to
float maybe the morally appropriate
thing to do is jump off right to save
everybody else not to pretend that well
who is it is it the Africans who don't
get to have fossil fuels for example is
it people all over the world the poor
people who are multiplying so rapidly
they're devouring the planet's resources
should they all
and so I have absolutely no qualms
whatsoever about calling someone out on
it especially when I'm doing it
obviously
ironically now they actually said the
bloody College said the complaint was I
was counseling to
Suicide okay now really who is stupid
enough to think that well obviously the
Canadian College of psychologists and
the Canadian
courts so there's another one there's
another one that kind of goes along with
that where you're clear joking and this
is what they say uh so this is from The
Joe Rogan podcast speaking about air
pollution and child deaths Dr Peterson
said it's just poor children and the
world has too many people on it anyways
which is
clearly
sarcasm that's in there though yeah yeah
well that's that's and those are the so
just so everybody's watching and
listening knows so you know someone can
take out a complaint by going filling
out a form at the Ontario College of
psychologist website so if anybody out
there is inclined to complain some more
just go ahead and do it but the college
doesn't have to pursue those complaints
because they can Define them as
vexatious and and just troublemaking
right so it isn't even only that members
of the public the millions of people
that I'm communicating with let's say
are prone to complain but that the
college itself decided that that was
sufficient grounds to threaten my
license and to force force me into
re-education of course they're not doing
it for disciplinary reasons it's like
what the what the I don't even
understand what that means if you're not
doing it for disciplinary reasons it's
like why is it
forced and why am I being upated that's
like the definition of
disciplinary so that just shows you how
mendacious the the decision
is yeah yeah and then and then it does
go to outline
that it's directed Dr Peterson enter a
coaching program with either one or two
individuals identified the P by the
panel to review reflect on and
ameliorate his professionalism in public
statements the coaching program was to
begin within three months and to be
completed within 12 costs associated
with the coaching are borne by you it
also outlines that coaching doesn't end
until you've successfully ameliorated
your professionalism and learned
something yeah and so and what the hell
is that supposed to mean precisely I'd
need a whole personality transplant
apparently but there's another problem
too there and here's the problem I'm not
wrong so that's a big problem and I I
swear I will do
this if I am required to undergo the
retraining I will undergo the
retraining and I will tape it and I will
broadcast it and then everyone else can
decide um
then everyone else can decide for
themselves just exactly what the hell's
going on and whether or not I've
contemplated my words whether or not
I've thought through everything I say
carefully whether or not I have any
grounds for my opinions you know I don't
say things that I haven't thought about
and thought about a lot and so I agree
with Canadians that Justin Trudeau is
the worst prime minister that the
country has ever had and I think he's
actually far worse than people think and
I think that Professionals in Canada no
longer have the right to express their
thoughts which makes which invalidates
them as useful professionals and I think
they're pushed into a corner so badly
that even the brave professionals I know
and I do know some are unwilling to
fight this to even make public
statements in support of me and if you
think that is the Hallmark of a free
country there is really something wrong
with you you bloody well better wake up
and if you think that if that's
happening to professionals that it's not
going to happen to you well you are
exactly naive enough to deserve exactly
what's coming down the pipeline for
you I I guess one of the problems I see
is okay so you're in a good position to
fight this even though it's costing it
is seriously costing an arm and a leg um
and it's timec consuming and it's
stressful but at least you're not
reliant on your clinical practice for
livelihood right yeah as opposed to
other people what
what's the average Canadian supposed to
do when they're living in a in a society
like this like how do you fight because
in my opinion I don't know I honestly
don't know if you're you can win this I
think Canada is crooked and
woke very very deep down so I don't
necessarily see this going in a good
direction for your clinical license at
least in Ontario what are average people
supposed to do to try and stop their
society from going in this kind of
Direction CU it feels like like I moved
I just ran away I was like goodbye to
this country I'm going to America it has
its problems for sure but at least
there's freedom of speech built in there
like what's the average Canadian do to
fight back against this get involved in
the political process at whatever level
they can get involved in the school
boards get involved in the political
parties get involved in local elections
volunteer for election start start
differentiating between the false
government state funded Legacy news and
actual news if you can do that even
though that's impossible in Canada too
because now Canadians can't get news
it's like look here's the rule Mick this
is the rule all responsibility on the
political front abdicated by the average
citizen will be taken up by tyrants and
used against you and so you either take
responsibility for this which means to
get involved in the political process or
you suffer the consequences now you know
a young person might be thinking well
what could I do and I would say you know
that's actually not a good attitude and
I mean that practically because what you
will find if you're young if you go
volunteer for a political campaign let's
say first of all you're going to learn a
lot you're going to sharpen your
political beliefs you're going to learn
how to put an argument forward and then
if you're competent and hardworking
you're going to find that Avenues of
opportunity open for you on the
political front so quickly that you can
hardly imagine it and that's partly
because most political organizations
are chronically short of help and
absolutely chronically short of
competent help and so if you stepped
into the political Arena you'd learn to
speak more fluently you'd learn to put
your arguments together you'd learn to
be more responsible you'd take the
responsibility onto yourself and
strengthen yourself as a consequence
you'd keep the country on the straight
and narrow and you'd keep it free and
all sorts of opportunities would emerge
for you and so that's what you do now
people don't do that and it's partly
also because they're taught oh you know
the whole system is so corrupt that
nothing can be done about it it's
like well if that's the case you're in
real trouble and if it's not the
case take advantage of the opportunity
get out there do something about it you
know you're a citizen it means you have
some responsibility and you're a citizen
without responsibility you're headed for
slavery simple as that that's how the
world works if you don't stand up for
yourself obviously the people who will
exploit you will exploit you
obviously so I don't think it is
hopeless at all I think that
Canadians I think that the fundamental
Bedrock of our institutions is still
solidly enough in place although it is
threatened that we don't have to walk
down this increasingly authoritarian
route and you know there's some positive
signs one of them being for example that
the bloom is off the Trudeau
Rose you know there's a man who couldn't
even tell the truth about his
marriage what's the alternative you know
you said for example you left well there
were business reasons for that too
because it does turn out that the United
States is a place much more it's much
more straightforward to do business in
the United States and yeah most people
who are watching and listening will not
know that Canadians are
now Canadians now make 60% as much as
Americans make
60% and the gap capap is growing and
that's a huge difference we were at
parody in the 1970s it's a catastrophic
difference and Trudeau and his bloody
minion Steven Gilbo Prime among them are
doing he said today Gilbo said today
that the days of free and plentiful
energy are over well there's no
difference between energy and wealth and
and there's particularly no difference
between energy and wealth for poor
people you want to make poor people poor
make energy expensive energy is work you
make work expensive you you demolish the
poor
obviously well I object to that that's
why I object to the climate
fear-mongering apocalyptic lies because
it destroys the poor just so that the
people who are screeching about the sky
fall falling can feel momentarily moral
about their role as planetary savior
it's like no to hell with you
seriously you leave the poor alone
there's also definitely not one person
who's screeching about the sky fall
falling in terms of climate that's
having problems affording energy not one
of those people can't afford
heat yeah well that's exactly right
that's exactly right it's it's
um the people who are struggling to put
food on their table and to keep their
air conditioners on to keep their
heaters on in the winter they're not
playing moralistic games on the
planetary savior side of things no
they're just trying to Scrabble for
forward with a certain degree of hope
it's appalling to see the left support
this for example because in principle
the left is the voice of the underclass
let's say and it's obvious that the
progressives will sacrifice the poor to
Nature right to Nature worship to Gaia
this imaginary catastrophe that
justifies degrowth for example what the
hell do you think degrowth means if you
you don't think that means starving poor
people you're an idiot and you might say
well there's too many people on the
planet anyways in which case I would say
then leave well is there anything else
you think we should get into details
about this or does that give people a
good idea about what's going on we can
continue updating people but this is the
this is the big story now hopefully we
can get this covered by Insurance
because oof well insurance for a
practitioner is mandatory
and insurance for a practitioner is
mandatory for these
reasons and so it would be quite the
situation if it turned out that the
insurance which I was
paying because that was
mandatory also fails to
cover this sequence of events so we'll
see about
that but I'll take
this I will take this as far as
necessary
so and like if I tell you m
Mick I am very much inclined as you know
to if I'm accused of doing something to
rake myself over the coals and to try to
find out if I did something wrong and I
went through those allegations at
Christmas in detail and it was very
stressful because I thought you know
well yeah maybe there's something here
and that I went beyond the bounds of
reasonable conduct
and I was very apprehensive there were
13 charges at that point they've dropped
seven God only knows why they dropped
those
seven it's just arbitrary but I went
through all 13 in detail hundreds of
pages of
allegations and when I came out of that
I thought well first of all I thought
how daed can you be to pursue
allegations put forward by people who
lied about the fact they were clients of
mine you know th those should have been
just taken off the table instantly
obviously you can't start by trusting
the word of someone who lies in writing
about something fundamental so that was
kind of a relief in some sense right
because I thought well that sheds a
pretty dim light on the procedures of
the college and then I went through each
allegation in turn and I think the most
damning as I said was the tweet in
relationship to Elliot page that was
certainly the one that caused the most
public trouble it's like I got to tell
you kiddo that's looking pretty good
now
so
despite my proclivity to feel guilt
which is quite substantive and despite
my temperamental unwillingness to engage
in
Conflict I don't
see not only do I not see what I did
wrong I think what I've done on the
Public Communication front is my
responsibility as a
clinician to tell the truth about what I
see and
so
so we'll make it public in every
possible way and I'll bring to bear
every single bit of public pressure I
can possibly muster on this particular
topic and we will watch over the next
three years because that's how long
it'll take exactly how this plays out so
and I've you know we've cordoned off our
life I can deal with this without it
having interfere with everything else
I'm doing I've talked to Tammy I've
talked to you and Julian my family's on
my side we're solidly committed to this
I have a good legal team we have the
money necessary to do this and we have
the connections so if the college wants
to re-educate
me they're more than welcome to
try but if they think they're going to
do it in
secret they've got another think
coming
well with that it was nice talking to
you have fun at the presidential debate
tonight I like your
suit oh thank you isn't it ridiculous
yeah it's good you stand out I like it
very Sol yeah yeah yeah well I thought
I'd blend in with the crowd tonight you
know you know the Americans they're very
theatrical right this everything
Americans do is theatrical and so this
presidential debate it's theater of the
best sort and I'm down here to have an
adventure you know and
so and it's what I should be
concentrating
on and my writing you know
but in for a penny in for a
pound that's for sure
yeah okay
kiddo bye I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
byebye